So there's a guy who called into C-SPAN after
the first deranged and depraved evening of
the Republican National Convention.
And the guy called in and said said he's a
lifelong Democrat, but the first night of
the Republican convention has convinced him
to switch his vote and vote for Donald Trump.
Now, I'm going to play the call for you in
a moment, but what I want to raise ahead of
time is in reaction to what I'm about to play
for you.
There's a lot of people who are debating,
is the guy for real or is he a troll?
Is this for real or is the guy faking?
And he's really a Trump guy who just called
C-SPAN and said that he's a lifelong Democrat.
I have some thoughts about that.
But I'm actually going to make the case that
it doesn't matter.
And I'll explain why.
But first, let's take a look at the video.
Rick in Lorain, Ohio, Democrat.
Hi, Rick.
Tonight, I'm a lifelong Democrat.
I'm from Ohio, which is a Democrat city in
Ohio.
And I just want to say, after watching the
convention tonight on TV on C-SPAN here, I
am definitely changing my vote to Republican.
And I'll tell you what, they just put the
Democratic Party as the Republican Party to
shame.
I'm going to follow the Republican Party now.
But why what what what was it that convinced
you about tonight?
It was the heartfelt way they came across
to the American people.
And I was really touched by the number of
times I use the word God.
They put God into everything.
And the people on the Democratic side or near
convention act like they were pushing God
right out of it.
And that's had a lot to do with change in
my mind now.
Rick, did you say you were a union member?
No, sir.
I'm from Lorain, Ohio.
And we are a Democrat town here and have been
for 50 years.
That's it.
Thank you so much.
So in terms of whether this is for real or
where this is, whether this is really a Trump
guy who is lying, that he's a lifelong Democrat,
the guy said that he's calling from a Democrat
city in Ohio.
I've never met a lifelong Democrat who calls
cities Democrat cities.
That's how the Wright talks.
That's literally a term out of Trump's playbook
from the last two or three years.
So I think that there's certainly reason to
doubt whether this guy is sincerely a lifelong
Democrat who was convinced to switch and vote
for Trump from night one of the DNC, from
the RNC, rather.
But it doesn't matter.
Okay.
This is sort of like looking at retail versus
wholesale.
The question isn't whether this one guy was
really convinced to vote for Trump because
of the RNC.
Someone in a country of 331 million people
with 120 to 135 million expected to vote,
someone I'm sure is going to be convinced
to vote.
Trump, who was previously thinking they were
going to go vote Biden by the RNC.
The point is the big picture first, it's the
big picture of conventions.
If history is an indicator, conventions don't
really do much for either candidate.
Typically, what you see is one candidate has
a convention and they get a little bump and
then the other candidate has a convention
and they get a little bump and then it fades.
And by October, nobody remembers it.
And we've moved on to other things.
The right has tried to make the case that
there is a massive movement of Democrats abandoning
the Democratic Party and jumping ship to vote
for Donald Trump.
It's not backed up by the data that we have.
There is no doubt that there are disaffected
Democrats who don't like the fact that Joe
Biden is a candidate.
Some of them are going to stay home.
Some of them are going to vote for Donald
Trump.
Likewise, there are people who voted Trump
in 2016 who are going to vote for Biden.
There is no evidence right now that there
are large numbers of Democrats defecting to
the Republican Party or planning to vote for
Donald Trump.
The one caller is not really newsworthy, but
there is the more interesting.
Deeper question about the bigger picture here,
which is, are people switching parties?
What we know is that most 2016 Trump voters
are going to vote for Trump again.
What we know is that most 2016 Hillary voters
are going to vote for Biden.
What we know is that independents are leaning
towards Joe Biden.
And ultimately, this is going to come down
to who votes in which states and how much
of the vote can Donald Trump suppress.
So maybe it's true that this particular guy
was a lifelong Democrat and he was convinced
after a life of voting for Democrats to vote
for Donald Trump because of Kimberly Guilfoyle
screaming on Monday night at the Republican
National Convention, or as he says, because
the Republican convention kept mentioning
God.
The truth, of course, is that in reality,
Joe Biden is more religious than Donald Trump.
It's not something I care about.
But for people who want a religious candidate,
there's no question that Donald Trump's religiosity
is completely fabricated and fake as something
to appeal to evangelical voters.
With Trump as a politician, whereas Joe Biden
actually seems to be a moderate, moderately
devout Catholic, I don't care about that.
But if you're looking for the religious candidate,
it's not Donald Trump.
It's Joe Biden up.
But sure, the caller might be making it up
as well.
It doesn't matter if we all go out and vote,
period.
And that is ultimately going to be the ones
has it.
It's not.
Did this guy switch in Ohio, by the way?
Ohio.
Not looking as good for Joe Biden as it did
before, or I guess better said, looking better
for Donald Trump recently than it did before.
What matters is if we all go out and vote
and the large numbers and so I wouldn't be
lulled into a false debate about whether it's
possible that the RNC really shifted a Democrat
into voting for Trump.
I'm sure some Democrats did get convinced
to vote Trump from the RNC and some Republicans
were convinced to vote for Joe Biden from
the DNC.
We're a country of 300 and 31 million.
The big picture is what matters.
Let's not lose sight of that in the big picture
is Trump's going to try to win by suppressing
the vote.
Trump's going to try to win by rigging the
election.
That's the big picture.
Not whether this
guy
is
a troll.